hey everyone its Peter Brown standing in
for freelance reviewer Miguel concepción
review of Pokemon go it's fitting that
pokemons most significant evolutionary
leap in its twenty-year history is on a
mobile platform which mirrors its humble
origins on the Gameboy we're going
outside with Pokemon go catching pokémon
with friends fighting over gyms and
making friends along the way
simulating a throwing motion a forward
swipe toward your target is all it takes
to trap basic Pokemon it's a credit to
the diverse behaviors of these beasts
that you can't lexa basically throw
pokeballs as you attempt to capture them
you have to factor in whether they can
fly jump or deflect incoming balls much
of Pokemon goes augmented-reality
infrastructure was already in place
things too developer nigh antics
location-based MMO ingress both games
feature point of interest check-ins and
territorial conflicts except that go
features three teams compared to ingress
as to designated conflict zones or no
gyms and landmarks are called poki stops
reminiscent of collectible card games
battling in a gym is a duel of stats and
hoping your cumulative abilities
outweigh your opponents there's added
depth in the actual battle which plays
out in real-time careful timing is
needed when attacking and dodging and
your stats determine the effectiveness
of your offensive moves as well as your
capacity to take hits what makes these
duels even more involved is the ability
to gang up on a gym team with multiple
concurrent battles the opportunity to
participate and excel in a group helps
lower the barrier to entry for newcomers
the nuances and timing of attacks and
dodges are learned through trial and
error and sharing experiences with
players in public you learn all the
advanced controls and tactics outside of
the game from adding spin your pokeball
to making special throws the sharing of
notes group capture sessions and bonding
through team battles our pokemon goes
social strengths and help fans ignore
the current absence of a key series
component Pokemon trading while some
form of trading is planned in the future
it's unfortunate that a feature
synonymous with the series isn't
President launched it is through rampant
collecting that goes showcases much of
its depth the chances of capturing the
same monster with the exact same stats
are astronomically low which makes
capturing multiples of the same Pokemon
a sound tactic health weight height
moveset and type are all factors that go
into a gym fight the most crucial
variable however is pokemons CP which
can be upgraded using candy and Stardust
the two currencies that you earn with
each capture Pokemon go stays true to
the franchise's strategic appeal even if
it doesn't offer the conveniences of
turn-based battles Pokemon gos monsters
litter the landscape often in accordance
to their terrain and the simple act of
exploring the real world will open
yourself up to a wider more diverse set
of potential captures this along with
the hi Jim countin cities underscores
the disadvantages of rural players many
of whom have relatively limited access
to rare Pokemon collecting give you a
communal effort because no one wild
Pokemon is exclusive to the first person
who captures it every player gets a fair
chance this experience can be greatly
enhanced with lures consumable items
that attract more Pokemon to a set
location much of the gear you need can
be acquired through general play by
leveling up and checking in at landmarks
the devoted players can spend cash on
una' central but useful items in classic
microtransaction fashion the majority of
Shop items merely accelerate the monster
collecting process whether you're using
lures or incense to attract Pokemon or
crack lucky eggs for a temporary
experience bonus beyond the bland map
art and the limited trainer character
design options is a lively world of
animated gyms and pokey stops during
capture events Pokemon counter your
pokeball throws with dodges and blocks
it's also common to approach a gym that
is currently in the midst of a power
struggle indicated by the amusing Looney
Tunes inspired whirlwind animation when
you join the fight it truly feels like a
team effort to see your buddies pokémon
battling at the far side of the arena
Pokemon goes after mentioned strengths
can't hide the fact that its initial
iteration is a buggy mess crash has come
during monster captures GPS
reconnections
and even when you're taking a screenshot
these issues occur often enough to cause
immense frustration but not enough to
make you want to give up altogether
Pokemon bows social hooks are that
strong if Pokemon goes initial public
reception is anything to go by its
ability to draw players from multiple
generations and varied gaming
backgrounds together is a game worthy of
attention when it works Pokemon go feels
like a natural evolution for the series
very much a product of the times without
making the main line series obsolete its
bugs and high battery consumption do not
outweigh the old but new thrill of
capturing Pikachu at a local park or
vanquishing a Snorlax while conquering a
gym